there's a narrative an idea that with
resilience grit and personal
responsibility
people can pull themselves up and
achieve economic success in the United
States we call it the American Dream a
similar narrative exists all over the
world
but the truth is that the challenges of
making this happen has less to do with
what we do and more to do with the
wealth position in which we're born so
I'm going to make the case that the
United States government actually that
any government should create a trust
account for every newborn of up to
$60,000 calibrated to the wealth of the
family in which they are born I'm
talking about an endowment
personal seed capital a publicly
established baby trust with my colleague
William Garrity at Duke University and I
have referred to as baby bonds a term
that was coined by the late historian
from Columbia University Manning Marable
the reason why we should create these
trusts is simple wealth is the paramount
indicator of economic security and
well-being it provides financial agency
economic security to take risk and
shield against loss without capital
inequality is locked in we use words
like choice freedom to describe the
benefits of the market but it is
literally wealth that gives us choice
freedom and optionality
wealthy of families a better position to
finance an elite independent school and
college education access capital to
start a business finance expensive
medical procedures reside in
neighborhoods with higher amenities
exert political influence through
campaign finance purchase better legal
counsel if confronted with an expensive
criminal justice system leave a bequest
and/or withstand financial hardship
resulting from any number of emergencies
basically when it comes to economic
security wealth is both the beginning
and the end I will frame this
conversation in the context of the
United States but this discussion
applied virtually to any country a
facing facing increasing inequality in
the u.s. the top 10% of households hold
about eighty percent of the nation's
wealth while the bottom sixty percent
owns only about 1%
but when it comes to wealth race isn't
even stronger predictor than class
itself blacks and Latinos collectively
make up 30% of the United States
population but collectively owned about
7% of the nation's wealth
the 2016 survey of consumer finance
indicates that the typical black family
has about $17,000 in wealth and that's
inclusive of home equity while the
typical white family has about 170,000
that is indicative of an absolute racial
wealth gap where the typical black
household has about 10 cents for every
dollar held by the typical white family
but regardless of race the market alone
has been inadequate to address these
inequalities even in times of economic
expansion inequality grows over the last
45 years wealth disparity has increased
dramatically and essentially all the
economic gains from America's increasing
productivity have gone to the elite or
the upper-middle class
yet much of the framing around economic
disparity focuses on the poor choices of
black Latino and poor borrowers this
framing is wrong the directional
emphasis is wrong it is more likely than
meager economic circumstance not poor
decision-making or deficient knowledge
constrains choice itself and leaves
people with no options but to turn to
predatory finance
in essence
education is not the magic antidote for
the enormous inherited disparities that
result from laws policies and economic
arrangement this does not diminish the
value of education indeed I'm a
university professor there clear
intrinsic values to education along with
a public responsibility to expose
everyone to a high quality education
from grade school all the way through
college but education is not the panacea
in fact blacks who live in families
where the head graduated from college
typically have less wealth than white
families where the head dropped out of
high school
perhaps we overstate the functional role
of education at the detriment of
understanding the functional role of
wealth basically it is wealth that
begets more wealth
that's why we advocate for baby trust an
economic birthright to capital for
everyone these accounts would be held in
public trust to be used as a foundation
to an economically secure life the
concept of economic rights it's not new
nor is it radical in
1944 President Franklin Roosevelt
introduced the idea of an economic Bill
of Rights Roosevelt called for physical
security
economic security social security and
moral security
unfortunately since the Nixon
administration the political sentiment
regarding social mobility has radically
shifted away from government mandates to
economic security to a neoliberal
approach in which the market is presumed
to be the solution for all our problems
economic or otherwise as
a result the onus of social mobility has
shifted on to the individual the
pervasive narrative is that even if your
lot in life is subpar with perseverance
and hard work and the virtues of the
free market you can turn your proverbial
rags into riches
of course the flipside is that the
virtues of market will likewise sanction
those that are not astute those that
lack motivation or those that are simply
lazy in other words the deserving poor
will receive their just rewards
what is glaringly missing from this
narrative is the role of power and
capital and how that power and capital
can be used to alter the rules and
structure of transactions and markets in
the first place power and capital
becomes self reinforcing and without
government intervention they generate an
iterative cycle of both stratification
and inequality
the capital finance provided by baby
trusts is intended to deliver a more
egalitarian and an authentic pathway to
economic security independent of the
family financial position in which
individuals are born the program would
complement the economic rights to
old-age pensions and provide a more
comprehensive Social Security program
designed to provide capital finance from
cradle all the way through grave we
envision endow American newborns with an
average account of
$25,000 that gradually Rises upwards to
$60,000 for babies born into the poorest
families babies born into the wealthiest
families would be included as well in
the social contract but they would
receive a more nominal account of about
$500
the accounts would be federally managed
and they would grow at a guaranteed
annual interest rate of about 2% per
year in order to curtail inflation costs
and be used when the child reaches
adulthood for some asset enhancing
activity like financing a debt-free
university education a down payment to
purchase a home or some seed capital to
start a business when approximately 4
million babies born each year in the US
if the average endowment of a baby trust
is set at $25,000 the program would
crudely cost about a hundred billion
dollars a year this would constitute
only about 2% of current federal
expenditures and
far less than the 500 plus billion
dollars that's already being spent by
the federal government on an asset
promotion through tax credits and
subsidies at issues it's not the amount
of that allocation but to whom it's
distributed currently the top one
percent of households those earning
above a hundred million dollars receive
only about one third of this entire
allocation while the bottom 60% receive
only five percent if the federal asset
promoting budget were allocated in a
more progressive manner federal policies
could be transformative for all
Americans
this is a work in progress there are
obviously many details to be worked out
but it is a policy proposal grounded in
the functional roles and the inherited
advantages of wealth that moves us away
from the reinforcing status quo
behavioral explanations for inequality
towards more structural solutions our
existing tax policies the privileged
existing wealth rather than establishing
new wealth is a choice the extent of our
dramatic inequality is at least as much
a problem of politics as it is a problem
of economics it is time to get beyond
the false narratives that attribute
inequality to individual personal
deficits while largely ignoring the
advantages of wealth
instead
public provisions of a baby trust could
go a long way towards
eliminating the transmission of economic
advantage or disadvantage
across generations and establishing a
more moral and decent economy that
facilitates assets economic security and
social mobility for all its citizens
regardless of the race and the family
positions in which they are born thank
you very much
sorry I
mean there's um that there's so much to
like in this idea there's this one
there's one piece of
branding around it that I worry about
which is just that like right now trust
fund kids have a really bad rap you know
they're the sort of eyeball rolling
posted children for how money kind of
takes away motivation so that the these
trusts are different so how do you show
people in this proposal that that is
it's not going to do that if you know
you have limited resources or if you're
gonna face discrimination there's a
narrative that well the economic returns
to investing myself are lower than that
of someone else so I might might as well
enjoy my leisure of course there's
another narrative as well so we
shouldn't get caught on that code up on
that you know somebody who's poor and
gonna face discrimination they also
might pursue a resume building strategy
the old adage I have to be twice as good
as someone else now when we say that we
never ask at what cost are their health
costs associated with that now I haven't
answered your question but coming back
to your question if you know you're
gonna receive a transfer at a later
point in life that only increases the
incentive for you to invest in yourself
so that you can better use that trust
yeah you're giving people possibilities
of lives that they currently cannot
imagine having and therefore the
motivation to do that I could talk with
you for hours about this thank you so
much for I'm really glad you're working
on this
[Applause]